this one
[Music]
what are we doing
step down for me
any idea on you
just go who's in this
yours where'd you get it from
I'm sorry rental shop where do you live
where can you turn that thing off for me
so I can hear you
appreciate it
I'm sorry I'm good yeah
where do you
where do you live
Lucy County Volusia County what are you
doing up here I'm just working with you
you're working up here
you realize you were hitting some things
back there yeah I know
well I mean why are we driving this
thing down the sidewalk
I like to take it down the road well
hold on where did you where'd you get
this equipment from yeah the rental
place
where there's no rental place around
here so it's down here other places
you're throwing it on the tractor
trailer okay where's the tractor trailer
that this came off of it's in the back
here
do you work over there yes okay who's
who so you rented this or your boss
rented this I see my ball suit you're in
Boston huh
whose bike and stuff is this
your your bike
okay
it looks like it's broken
how'd you get up here
huh
how'd you get up here this bike where
were you taking this
construction site okay you got a phone
on you yeah all right can you call your
boss and have them come up here it's not
active okay
all right
hold on a second do me a favor
well I got you put your hands behind
your back for me you're not under arrest
you're just being detained at this time
okay
because
so I can conduct my investigation and we
can figure out what's going on here okay
so I don't want to get caught on your
watch
[Applause]
we'll we'll talk in one second okay
because I'm going to read you some
yeah
let's come over here and we'll sit up
top front of my car